so is your voice actor and an idol yeah
right is that like a percentage of which
side you tend to do more or is it like
many people Idol who voice acts or my
voice yeah when people ask you what you
do do you say voice actor or idle I say
voice actor just because I want to be a
voice
sometimes when um like in situations you
know when you know saying an idol would
work better you know like if I screw up
so badly
as a voice actor somewhere I'm gonna be
like I'm sorry
yeah
I'm sorry
like sometimes I would pull the idle
card like during like my um I also do
have a YouTube channel yeah right like
for the title like you know
um I use Idol and voice actor depending
on like which one would be funnier you
know in the context you know so you
didn't know you're going to be an idol
you passed the audition yeah like you're
an idol and you're like oh God what do I
what happened was this the first
audition that you did no I took a lot of
voice acting auditions but I failed a
lot of them because I usually um make it
to the final stage with my English but
during the final stage they would
usually give you a script and they're
like look at it for 30 seconds and read
it and I'm like okay well I could look
at it but I can't read it
yeah you could give me an hour I
wouldn't know how to read this
yeah but it was also a problem when I
first went into voice acting school oh
my gosh yeah this has never happened
what's up there's something wrong with
our uh
I think it's overheating
we'll be able to keep doing it sorry
about that yeah when I the voice acting
school that I went to
um for you to get in there was a written
test as well which I didn't know oh yeah
and what's on this written test like uh
it's to see if you could if you know
basic Japanese you know because there's
you know there's a lot of people who
want to be voice actors but they're like
you know like we need you to have like
basic links together but I couldn't read
a single just sweating yeah I'm like oh
no so I took out a red pen and I wrote
I'm sorry I'm from America
but like right after that there was also
like an acting test too so my
pronunciation was like okay so like you
know even if I couldn't read or write
you know I was like I could like speak
you know well so that just sounds like
every exam experience I've had I'm just
like I can't do this section but I'm
gonna try and Ace this section okay this
section carries me for the section that
I'm that I suck at yeah how many schools
did you go to because I actually did a
video filming at one of the schools and
it was one of the most embarrassing
experiences of my life because I had to
voice act in Japanese in front of people
who were doing this seriously yeah they
were all very kind about it and they all
came basically just to film this video
that I was making yeah I felt so bad
there to sit there and listen to me
butcher the language
um but like there was like one thing I
found really interesting is that it
wasn't like you it's not just one voice
acting school that's like you'd have to
work your way up the different tiers of
voice acting yeah right the one that I
filmed at was like a an agency had would
select you to join it and you were in
like kind of like the upper echelon of
of the like
um trainees wanting to get into voice
acting it's like a weird like costume
okay okay
because I had no acting skills but also
my Japanese sucks that had every reason
to be in the beginning do a lot of
people progress that's one thing that I
didn't really get to ask them or learn
about so I didn't know the rate of like
progression the very people who would
drop out
I I mean I know by the time um I was
only there at that school for like six
months because I got into the this group
that I'm in another business in like six
months so um but by those like months
already half the class was basically
gone okay yeah so a lot of dropouts or a
lot of people address yeah a lot of
people dropped out climate is just
expensive as well right yeah it's really
expensive but like uh the one that I
went to was like one of the cheaper ones
yeah but I was so I was put in the
beginner class but on day one there was
a girl that was fluent in French I was
like damn I was gonna pull my English
cards
like this is how I was gonna get into
this agency but this girl who knows
perfect Japanese she's so pretty she has
a beautiful voice and she speaks perfect
French what an [__] I can't do this
right now
he'll be like I see this is a negative
so yeah but this is the beginner class
and I'm like you know if I can't be the
first in this beginner's class like
there's no way I'm gonna get into the
agency yeah you're like I gotta be the
best in the beginner class yes and it's
like if I can't be like the best year
like even if some miracle happens and I
get into an agency there's no way I can
compete against my seniors who are
already so good at it so then I started
going to a different like school who
taught you privately yeah right and um
that the principal at that teacher was
the one who actually introduced me to
Nana like the audition okay so so he
also thought this group was a voice
acting group
nobody had a clue
everyone is just really good at dancing
and pretty maybe yeah yeah no the
dancing part that oh my god there was
the audition process was so stressful
because
um for none of them did you ever dance
before I did figure I did competitive
figure skating oh okay wait wait
no ice rings in L.A
but yeah but you know figure skating and
just ballet and there's like slow
Movement Dance things it's just so
different from Idol dancing so but like
when I first got the Callback to be in
the third stage of this audition it was
two days before the third stage and they
were like you need to memorize this
dance like this so-and-so groups dance
but they didn't have like a video sent
to me okay so they were like just look
for it online so they gave you a
transcript be like
so the right leg goes off wow this is
the source look it up but like they gave
me the title so I looked it up there's
only you know how they're really strict
with copyright so yeah so I I see the
music video but first of all it's the
short version second of all it's a music
video so there's barely any dancing like
it's like lip sync of these pretty girls
and like what do you want me to learn
yeah so I went to this the audition not
knowing any of the choreography yeah
right and the girl that sat next to me
luckily she's my uh you know
future member as well yeah but she was
like do you want to go practice the
dance in the hallway I was like yes
please but I didn't want to be like
because I didn't I don't know the
choreography because I don't want to you
know
so I'll let you take the leader yeah I
was literally like how about we watch
each other dance and like give each
other like constructive criticism you go
first
and so she would dance in front of me
and I'm like how about you that looked
yeah
but she was like but I just you know she
knew that I was from America and my uh
cousin was a dancer so I borrowed her
clothes so I looked like a dancer
I knew what I was talking about so I was
like you should do the movements really
slowly because you know dance is just a
lot of poses put together so you should
just like do it more slowly here I'll do
it with you so she's like she's like
doing it walking me through this step
he's just like violently staring just
trying to remember everything it's like
do that part again just one more time
please yeah yeah so then but then once I
memorize it I'm like I think we're good
we should go back
and I will now Ace this exam
and then it was you know the time for
the dance audition you know all these
like different groups we were put in
different groups
and while we were dancing I saw that one
of the judges had a video camera
um going around filming us it was
obvious he wasn't filming a stance and
he was like my face right because I was
like they don't care about the dance
it's about the Charisma
so I was like you know what I'm gonna
wink at the judges
so yeah
um everybody else is like dancing really
seriously and you know I just learned
danso halfway through I forget it yeah I
don't have any like games just like just
just just cut just fill me up here just
don't film any of my body because I'm
not moving I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know what I'm doing this sounds
like an entire anime
this literally sounds like the Naruto
test they did well like an example
the dancing was the red herring they
didn't care about the dogs you know did
the plot armor
that's crazy I watched enough animated
[Applause]
at which point did you find out that uh
you were auditioning for an idol group
once I got in and
[Laughter]
people will just audition for [__] they
don't know what it is yeah they don't
know yeah like once I got in and they
started caring about uh my weight and
stuff I was like why would you care
about my weight you know like you know
wait how does that conversation go are
they like hey what is that is that like
a granola bar how many carbs so
um you know everybody like a majority of
the members were teenagers so my parents
had to come in for a meeting before you
know signing the contract and right then
and there they told me they were like
you should probably lose like 10
kilograms jeez but the thing was I wrote
um on my resume oh should I stop talking
yeah that's very loud
distractions she's been very unfortunate
yeah yeah so I I lied on my resume
saying like I was 10 kilograms lighter
do you feel that they were just
arbitrarily picking a number that they
were like this is thin like but yeah
because like it's really different you
know like muscle mass and everything so
they're like you don't know what you're
talking about yeah so I would go I'll
have you know my BMI is perfectly normal
actually yeah I do like that throughout
this entire thing you've been like
pushing back in your own way against
every single like yeah yeah like almost
unnecessarily stereotypical thing
they've been asking for yeah no I'm not
gonna do that I've somehow successfully
Uno reverse caught every conversation
yeah why did it worked yeah it worked I
mean I mean I guess it didn't work
because they told me to lose them
yeah I mean it worked during the resume
part but like I guess they were like we
know you're lying kind of thing but yeah
did you lose 10 no okay
well the thing was that meeting was
during winter and I was wearing like my
mom's coat that was this big
yeah right so during the summer next
like the next summer like I you know um
I have like a fairly skinny waist
because with like figure skating and
everything so like I get a lot of that
on my face so like during the summer I
would wear like a really tight clothes
and be like since last winter I lost 10
kilograms I just took the code off damn
she did it oh my God sorry I don't know
why this is the first time it's ever
happened do you think it's overheating
yeah it's most definitely is do we have
a fan in the office sure it has a fan
built in I don't know why it's not bad
okay can we get some do you have any ice
or cold stuff that we can put it on yeah
maybe
all right sorry about that this has
never happened before of course the one
day we're honest
um okay so you got in Lost okay so so
how did they explain to you that you're
going to be part of an idol group was
that part of the conversation when the
contracts were being signed they never
really like explained it explained it it
was more like
um the more interviews you do with like
all these magazines and the way the
staff members would explain to you how
you should explain the group they always
use the word like idle group and I'm
like where's the voice acting part of it
kind of sounds to me like uh they didn't
really say anything until you like you
got on stage you kind of realized what
the what the hell am I doing here this
is like a new concept as well like Idols
or voice actors this is like a first of
its kind or um I mean there was like of
course love live and I don't know and
stuff but I think it was the first time
you know a producer for a lot of idol
groups The Godfather okay it was the
first time he produced an idol group
like voice actor and Idol group so I
think that's why the idol part is really
strong he's the guy who created like
akb48
yeah so he's considered like the
Godfather of the idol world yeah
basically okay what was the what was the
first gig you had when you like was it
like a it must have been a shock just
the first time actually having to do
idle stuff it was just a lot of dance
lessons like it was like two days of
dance lessons and like two hours of
voice acting lessons
a bit off
wrap ice on to it yeah okay okay sorry
oh no that sucks
show like we swap so that
like when that switches off since it's
over here I mean it's still gonna look
weird okay we can just make a note of it
that we just keep turning it on I think
yeah okay okay uh what are we again um